If we decide that the beverage is fine to drink now, that means we're accepting
the null hypothesis. However the beverage is actually too hot and you burn your
tongue. So the state of the world, or reality, is that the beverage is too hot.
Therefore we've committed a type II error. If we decide that the beverage is
fine to drink now and indeed it is. Then we accepted the null hypotheses and
the null is actually true. So we made the correct decision. If you think the
beverage is too hot. That means you're agreeing with the alternative
hypotheses. But if it's actually fine now, in other words the null is true.
Then we're committing a type I error. And finally, you think the beverage is
too hot, so you accept the alternative. And indeed, the alternative is true.
Or, H0 is false. So we made the correct decision.